I was born into a rich family. I enjoyed work and liked people to think well of me.
Everybody was certain that I had a good future ahead of me.
My biggest fault was that I enjoyed the pleasures of life too much.
I wanted people to think I was serious and a very good person...
...that did not do anything bad.
Because of this, I hid my pleasures.
When I was old enough to think about what I was doing,...
...I realized that I was living a double life.
I began to study science.
After a few years, I began to realize that a man is not one person.
He is two people.
I was usually the serious man who did good things.
The man who lived for pleasure was a dream that I could not always follow.
I began to think about the possibility of the two people being separate.
I tried to find a chemical that would help me make one of my spirits stronger than the other.
One night, I put the chemicals together in a glass.
They boiled and changed color. I drank the mixture.
I immediately felt very sick. Everything in my body hurt.
I did not know what would happen to me.
Then, the pain began to go away, and I stopped feeling sick.
I felt different. Then I realized that I was shorter.
I wanted to see myself. Did I really look different?